hey come on pull up a chair sit down say
hi to Christopher Walken hello today
we're gonna talk about something I might
have talked about a few times in the
past it's a maniac Susan yes so what if
it is I know I talked about several
times on the show but I can't help it
it's just so damn good not to but this
time we're counting down the absolute
best of the best
we're looking at the top 11 best
episodes of one the greatest TV shows
ever which one's had the best animation
the cleverest writing and the most
laughs and now there are two exceptions
to keep in mind one I'm not including
the salt it just wouldn't be fair the
songs are so good they deserve a list of
their own it won't make sense to have
half the countdown taken up with them
number two I'm not including the star
Warner's episode because those
technically thinking the brain it was
their final episode and as great as it
was it technically doesn't count as an
animated export but aside from that
everything else is totally fair game and
we're gonna look at the top 11 bus of
them here today why top 11 yes yeah well
you get the idea this is the top 11 best
Animaniacs episodes
number eleven Kari okey-dokey its
premise is just as funny as its
execution William Shatner has taken over
a karaoke for kids event and it's up to
the Warner's to get him to stop that's
about it but honestly that's about all
you need I'm trying to fill their lives
with joy then you should stop singing
right now this is mocking Shatner's
infamously horrible singing of rocket
man's oh my darling oh my darling Oh My
Darling Clementine as well as playing
off as equally infamous ego most like an
election ballot from Chile the
impersonation is great as well as the
Warner's always on beat mockery and
manipulation I'm not angry I am calm and
cool it's my turn to stop it your turn
to stop it hey that's not what I said
it's my turn to stop it the sharp speed
animation of shatners over-the-top
performance also manages to hit a
bull's-eye baa baa black sheep have you
any wool
top it off with a wing to bilbo baggins
and you have one hell of a funny episode
number 10 yes always most kids who
watched this episode we're just kind of
confused on the surface it doesn't seem
especially funny but when you know the
background for it it's absolutely
hilarious the brain is called in to do
voiceover work for an episode of
Animaniacs it seems to consist of
commercials and narrations with the
brain getting frustrated at the mediocre
writing you can emphasize beef that's
like wanting me to emphasize in before
July come on fellas you losing your
heads and again that's about it well how
on earth is that supposed to be funny
well the whole episode is satirising the
outtakes of world-famous director and
actor or as Anne Welles the inspiration
behind the brain's voice but you can't
emphasize beef that's like is wanting me
to emphasize in before July come on
fellas you're losing your heads over the
years the recording of this narration
has gotten more popular notably for
Orson Welles being amazingly impossible
to work with this episode is an homage
to his temper tantrum saying almost line
for line the exact same complaints get
me a jury and show me how you can say in
July and I'll make cheese for you get me
a jury and show me how you can say hinge
along and go down on you well I said
almost the actor for the brain maurice
lamarche was set to warm up using wells
as words from this recording so the
writers decided to make one giant and
joke and have the whole episode
dedicated to it in fact the writers and
directors even put themselves in the
episode leave go out brain I am the
director you were the director I can't
believe that guy i tacked Hart lead him
on his first job
the djoko's especially meta when brain
says nobody can replace him only to find
that there's a ton of impersonators
waiting outside
this is especially fitting seeing how
LaMarche has dove for Wells on several
occasions so it's something of an
impersonation of an impersonation of an
impersonation just idiotic you you'll
forgive me my sense that's just stupid
impossible meaningless that's just
idiotic if you'll forgive my saying so
that's just stupid
impossible meaningless yeah most kids
wouldn't get it but when you're an adult
it brings on all the laughs this is a
lot of you don't it
number nine Surrey yaks a lot a pretty
straightforward episode a dragon is
loose in Camelot and when King Arthur's
knights can't destroy it
Merlin magically conjures up the
Warner's to defeat it a new call for the
bravest most daring knight in all the
land
oh yes well too bad you got us let us
silly mix-up again very basic but the
jokes and the references are so many and
so quick it's hard not to laugh your ass
off one of the many highlights is the
references to the Camelot Musical itself
everything from Richard Harris's
spastically changing voice please pause
the ketchup Oh to the total uselessness
of syllabus song sequences we shall call
the beasts posh singing but the
references don't stop there
there's throwbacks to dr. Strangelove
Doug Henning and even Godzilla I know
Harry Mason I fear for all humanity the
speed of this episode is also what makes
it so much fun every second something is
appearing exploding screaming or being
smashed
there's a wonderful kinetic energy that
flows throughout the entire thing
there's even a great twist on the
Dragons identity that I won't ruin here
but trust me why say it's yet another
welcome campy oh I can't thank you
enough I'll try anyway it's medieval
xenian us at its best
number eight this is definitely one of
the more clever ideas to come out a show
for one whole episode all the Anna
maniac characters which rollers that's
right instead of pinky in the brain it's
Mindy in the braids instead of Rita and
runt it's pesto and runt the list goes
on and on to make for some of the show's
best interactions jeez ten thousand
years older than sand how can you be
brother that's just that's it I'm out of
here
in many respects this place to the heart
about why these characters are so strong
and memorable the personalities are so
big that all you need to do is switch
them up and watch them work off each
other
I know I know I'm supposed to sing fine
la la la la that was good oh you think
it was great no but I were you Clyde it
doesn't need that many twists and turns
just one funny personality working off
of another funny personality even the
shorter ones get a laugh my personal
favor is Rita and pinky just for help is
are we short and yet delightfully cruel
it what do you want to do tonight later
I don't know you two for supper hmm
so far this is my favorite episode when
you have characters this funny and
likeable all you have to do is put them
in a simple situation and see how they
react then this in many respects is the
simplest situation just switching the
roles for an episode so basic and yet so
effective we fill in all the characters
now that well make some
number seven
meatballs consequences / hot bothered
and bedeviled I'm cheating a little bit
here because both of these have very
similar setups the warner's going up
against an entity of the afterlife in
one of the South are going up against
the Grim Reaper to get their deceased
brother back and in another they're
going up against the devil himself to
dig their way out of hell not only do
they have similar funny setups but they
also have similar funny foils both the
devil and the Reaper are some of the
funniest foes they've ever gone up
against the Reaper wields a thick
Swedish accent obviously paying homage
to Swedish filmmaker Ingmar Bergman's
Seventh Seal about a knight who fight
for his life against death I haven't
lost the check or since time began when
was that I think it was a Tuesday there
are a few people know that he also seems
to be a stickler for rules and paperwork
the best part being when he thinks he's
fooled the warners with a loophole I
didn't pass the pesky little things that
renders all previous clauses and
amendments null and void but without
missing a beat the waters don't even
flinch and know they're going to make
his life a living hell take us for a
pony ride resulting in some great
reactions from our antagonist I don't
have the linguini with clams and
speaking of living hell the devil also
has some of the best voiceover delivery
out of all the villains his menacing
tone juggling with his monotone
frustration leads to some fantastic the
winner
I haven't had a day like this in some
time plus how cool is it to see the
Warner square off against the devil
himself it doesn't get any bigger than
that
hey frozen everything do you have any
idea how long it takes to get the pilot
Mitch
if the afterlife is full of this many
lives then we might just die of laughter
twice try and maintain the proper
attitude the fear and respect to do to
me by regulations at least tremble a
lethal number six
Bubba Bo Bob brain who would have
thought the country music scene would be
this much fun
to satirize well pinky and the brain did
and they came up with some great moments
the brain is looking to hypnotize the
world by playing a song that can put
anyone who hears it under his control so
seeing how this is during the Billy Ray
Cyrus era he chooses country music as he
knows people will listen to it over and
over and over
don't tell my hand lie empty hollow here
you know I understand but the commentary
of country music doesn't stop there
they said eyes everything from the
culture to the names to their
appearances I'm your biggest fan
what do you say to that I'd say puberty
was inordinately kind to you the design
of the legs are great too I love how
they always find new surreal proportions
for the brain to take on whenever he
pretends to be human this all leads up
to the brains big moment which is of
course ruined by the simplest of
mistakes as always but it's how
creatively the misunderstanding is going
to take place and it plays out great as
usual this is definitely a little ditty
worth watching a few times
hey ain't a fan I'm good either we're
gonna take a little break now so relax
go to the fridge grab a beer don't
forget to say hi to Chris for Walken
hello
you
welcome back did you have fun I have
lunch with Christopher Walken back to
the countdown
number five
when stocks lapping on top of educating
kids about an event that probably
wouldn't be taught about that much this
episode gives a great history as well as
satire to the music of the 60s and 70s
Skippy is fallen into the hippie crowd
much to us and Slappy's dismay thinking
a little time in the country would help
him be a little less pretentious she
also happens to pick the one spot
right in the middle of one of the
biggest concerts of all time Woodstock
when in history Woodstock I said no
event pulling together a whole
generation bowl full of prunes would
have the same effect
slappy tries her best to stop the
concert resulting in some pretty comedic
moments yes not only is the mocking of
the bands and their music a ton of fun
but it leads to one of the greatest oh
ma jizz - one of the greatest comic
routines ever who is on stage that's
what I'm asking you who is on stage
that's what I said you said who I sure
did
so tell me the name oh the name of the
group oh the group on stage
oh the great thing about it is even if
you don't know what the routine is based
off of it still holds up on its own
making fun of all the pretentious names
that came out of that time period do you
see the band on stage no I don't see the
band that's a different group entirely
there's the band you know that's not the
band of is performing later on because
it also has a great payoff as all the
explosions violence and rebelling only
makes the teens more interested in the
concert it looks like the only thing
that can scare them away is being
associated with something unpopular hey
everybody let's polka
it's a groovy episode with some groovy
laughs in the land of the free now
that's comedy number four
potty emergency everyone's had a run-in
like this you have to go to the bathroom
more than you ever have in your entire
life and of course there's no bathroom
in sight
well this sure pushes it to the nth
degree when whackos somehow can find
nowhere to go and the whole episode is
simply him and trying to find a place to
take a piss
as you'd expect absolutely everything is
tempting him only to make things worse
this might be some of the most graphic
imagery on the show without actually
being graphic at all it's so friggin
clever wackos already a funny character
but to see him in such pain for such a
long time is pretty rare resulting in
some great over-the-top reactions as
only Wakko can do oh also how many times
can you just hear him say potty
emergency without cracking up the
emergency potty emergency emergency so
simple yet so funny you'll piss your
pants with laughter number three
bumbie's up most of us have gone through
the trauma of watching Bambi's mom bite
the dust but we've all known that one
kid that took it just a little too hard
in this case it's Gibby who watches a
similar film called bum B with a similar
take on disposable Parenthood slappy
tries to convince him that was just a
movie but Skippy is still so heartbroken
so she decides to take him to see the
real actress who played the part
restoring his faith only to have a desk
yet again by another Disney classic the
animation on Skippy's childhood
constantly being assassinated might be
some of the funniest on the show like
buy a vowel plus the running joke that
Skippy is so destroyed that he can't
even mouth the words of what happened to
her bumpy's mom Lumpy's mothering
it's also kind of a touching episode we
know Slappy's a curmudgeon but it's
actually heartwarming when you see her
go to such lengths to try and make
Skippy feel better even if it doesn't
last very long funny touching with just
the right amount of mean-spiritedness
bumbie's mom knows how to bring on the
tears fade out already we got the joke
number two
spellbound this is the only episode to
start pinky in the brain throughout the
entire running time there's some cameos
here and there but this is the first one
to see if Pinky and the brain were
popular enough to hold an episode on
their own it was even rumored that this
was an unofficial pilot for the spin-off
series thankfully not only could they
hold an episode on their own but they
also made it one of the best in a time
of Wizards nights and magic Pinky and
the brain look to conjure up a brew to
grab them world domination there's only
one missing ingredient the toenail of a
dragon they set out to find it only to
come across a bunch of monstrous
entities which the brain uses is magic
one 2fort Charlie Sheen Ben Vereen
shrink to the size of a Lima Bean
no sometimes Charlie Sheen Ben Vereen
shrink to the side what makes this one
so good is not only that Pinky and the
brain are the stars not only that they
make fun of a bunch of fairy tales and
fantasies but it also has a pretty large
scale to it the climax in particular is
actually a pretty epic one the dragon is
chasing him down the spell is almost
cast it's a race against the clock and
pinky is singing the whole time the
ending as well might be one of the
funniest brain puts all his wants and
desires in jeopardy simply because of a
pet peeve inspired by pinky it's just so
funny that he would risk all of this for
a tiny yet frustrating annoyance this
resulted not only a great payoff but
maybe one of my favorite out-of-context
lines ever if I were into large cheese I
would make you pay for that remark say
that to your friend next time see how
they react it's a world of chases and
fantasy as only Pinky and the brain can
bring a lot one genius the others in
Pinky and the brain and the number one
best Animaniacs episode is hooked on a
ceiling not only is this one educational
not only does it have some of the
greatest writing not only does it have
some of the funniest animation not only
does it have some of the silliest
deliveries but practically every joke is
hit right out of the park
it's a comedic gold mine Michelangelo is
trying to finish the ceiling of the
Sistine Chapel if you're so great what
did you do with the other 15 chapels huh
got you there buddy gets so upset that
he fires all his painters leaving only
our wacky trio to save the day
we hate ceilings ceilings and only
ceilings we don't paint floors guys ever
need us this portrayal of Michelangelo
might seem a little strange seeing how
they're mocking Kirk Douglas even though
he played van Gogh but here it really
doesn't matter because it's just so damn
funny
that screeching voice matched with his
extreme expressions make him a laugh
riot how out you incompetent fools you
call yourselves artists on top of that
it makes his reactions to the Warner's
constantly destroying his years of hard
work all the more memorable it is
supposed to look like this
I wouldn't go flashing that around if I
were you Mike this is a church the
pacing the delivery the comic timing
everything is just perfect for this one
from the references Lakme nobody gets
him to see the Wizard not old buddy not
know how but I'm Michelangelo well now
that's a ceiling of a different color
the risky humor we're doing it because
we like bathing naked people even to the
most subtle of touches like the real
Michelangelo always said there was a
sculpture in every Rock looking to get
out only had to do was free it well here
he smashes a rock literally to reveal
one of the sculptures inside how can you
not love something so subtle it also has
the first use of one of the best visual
jokes of all time how out how dare you
how did that work what happened in
between those cuts we'll never know and
that's part of what makes it so freakin
great this joke was so popular that they
used it a couple times since I am
stupefied as to what has just occurred
from replacing his masterpieces with
kitsch to painting by numbers it all
builds up to the finishing of his magnum
opus birth of man again I won't reveal
the punchline here but let's just say
it's one of the funniest in all of the
show's history you don't have to be an
artist to appreciate the speed animation
acting and brilliant humor of easily the
greatest episode just can't get good
help these days if you want check out
more of the Animaniacs and all their
awesomeness go check them out on DVD
it's one of the greatest animated shows
of all time and trust me when I say it's
definitely worth the money I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and yeah good night
everybody
why won't anyone say hello to me
I wasn't even on the show
you
hey guys Doug Walker here and this is
the last time I'm going to talk about
c2e2 which is coming up this weekend and
I'm going to be a part of one of the
reasons I'm building it up so much is
because it really is a big con in
Chicago they have all sorts of big
celebrities and guest stars and stuff
like that and I have a table there and
it's very rare that I go to a con and
like I'm not doing panels I'm not being
pulled every which way and stuff so
you'll actually be able to come up and
speak to me at a table but not just me
of Rob Walker's gonna be there Jim J Roz
might be there and Brian Heinz less
angry geek Malcolm is gonna be there
Tamara sadly is not but all sorts of
people are going to be there and to find
it is very easy it's on the third floor
the exhibitor hall you just go to the
exhibitor hall you walk into the
entrance just go straight as soon as you
walk in just go straight to the back and
there I am there's the booth right there
Friday I'm going to get there at 12:00
and Saturday gonna get there twelve
Sunday it's the only day I'm gonna get
there at 10:00 when it opens because I
had to leave early that day I have to
leave at 1:30 cuz it got a job gotta
edit the videos and stuff uh but all the
other days I'm gonna get there at 12:00
and I'm just gonna stay until looks like
the people are drying up just so
definitely uh definitely show up there
say hi I love to say hello to you guys
like I said I've been to this calm
before it's really really cool and got a
lot of great stuff there and really hope
to see you guys there so well remember
that c2e2 and hopefully I will see you
guys there take care
you